hallo mein name ist flug habe meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einer neuen reaktion von mir
auf to how to handle eine nett fix wie
bei der es darum geht dass zehn reize
single models auf einer einsamen insel
sind allerdings nichts miteinander haben
dürfen wenn sie doch was haben geht von
ihrem hunderttausend dollar preisgeld
etwas runter und bei meiner letzten
rennen sind wir am ende bei der stelle
stehen geblieben wo zwei mädels
rumgeknutscht haben
von daher würde ich sagen schauen wir
jetzt weiter wie das halt weiter geht
haley kann unglaublich gut kissen und
schilder ist weder tun
ok schön dass es sich gelohnt hat denn
dieser kurs kostet die gruppe 3000
dollar
wie cool die sich auch für das habe ich
nach vorne und hinten nicht verstanden
die aktionär zufolge aber gut wir
erzählen keinen von unserem kurs so
verdächtigen sich alle gegenseitig und
wir gucken zu
wir tun so witte
seid ihr irre
dieser ihr müsst wissen die komplette
gruppe hat was gegen die beiden weil
diese teams zusammenhalten und die
gruppe ist er auf harrys seite will
harry hatte ja auch schon was mit ihr
mit francesca francesca pfalz zu den
anders mal haben wird es wohl so ist es
richtig mädels sei cool
diesem verdacht vor indem ihr zusammen
ins bett steigt
keine ahnung wer da irgendwie ein kurs
fabrizierter wenn alle zusammen schön
aussah francesca und hayley aber wir
wissen dass ihr seid ja kameras
verhalten euch diese nacht lieber genau
im auge
ja
erst mal gut macht jesus nicht nur das
an nachtsicht modus 229 francescas wach
geworden davon
ich sehe schon kommen alle verdächtigen
nachher die beiden obwohl die nichts
gemacht haben
duschen das dann auch in der dusche
sinken
[Musik]
die werden auch beim duschen gefilmt
menschenrechte sind ziemlich abstoßend
langer hat nunmal regeln aufgestellt
ich versuche mich daran zu halten sehr
gut rhomberg in der hoffnung dass mehr
als uns werden kann das war doch sogar
so der hintergedanke von der serie oder
die wollen ja diesen ganzen heißen
topmodel singles da auf dieser insel
beibringen hey führt nicht nur
oberflächliche beziehungen sondern
innere werte
hat bisher klasse geklappt seit einem
tag sind die da und es gab schon mehrere
verstöße
wenn ein spot kann okay du bist echt um
32 aufgestanden um uns das zu sagen
perfekt
in mir hat er ganz kurze arme oder
wirklichen oft rolle überhaupt nicht
böse gemeint aber man sieht einfach
immer so aus ich bin gespannt was jetzt
abgehen wird wels ecken slate
ich verwandle wasser in wein und gebe
euch gut solange eure rose bleiben
ja
genau die gleichen worte hat jedes jahr
auch damals gesagt war es nicht bloß das
ist die resort suppe harry und ich
werden da rein spucken und alles gut
durchrühren die zwei haben euch nichts
getan
die zwei haben euch absolut gar nichts
getan francesca ich finde das ist ne
hammer aktion gewesen man lerne heute
abend bekannt gibt es für 3000 dollar
verloren haben
wirst du die zwei beschuldigen ihre
hinterhältigen wie heißt das wenn man
sieht dass es hoffnung kleiner
silberstreif rettungsring der
schlupfloch das ist unser schlupfloch wo
ist das schlupfloch
haley
aber gut ich meine das war auch die die
nicht mehr weiß was wohl bedeutet also
war klar dass der mann ab und zu ein
paar wörter fehlen aber ich hab's
wirklich vorne und hinten nicht also
jahr francesca was mit harry und harry
hat das ganze initiiert hat aber dann
gesagt die auswahl von jazz schuld die
sache ist allerdings was alle anderen
damit zu tun
hier nimmt dadurch nicht harry geld weg
sondern euch allen alles dunkel
arschlöcher zwischen mir und chloe
stimmt definitiv die chemie
sie ist so unglaublich die lampe was
denkst du was ist mit dir eigentlich die
hat lokal auch etwas mit jesus einfach
sobald weil die beide sich so verstehen
so die beiden auf der gleichen new wave
die unterhalten sich dann über jesus und
jesaja genau bevor die spannung in
reserve schlägt man lerne unseren
singles ihren ersten workshops
was ist denn mit dem verstoß letzten
acht durch den bonner und einen
kopfhörer die workshops werden meinen
gästen die nötigen fähigkeiten
vermitteln und mit sich selbst und
anderen aufrichtige verbindungen
eingehen zu können okay ein wichtiger
schritt auf dem weg von bedeutungslosen
affären zu ernsten beziehungen
ja das wird harry und francesca
wahrscheinlich mega spaß machen und ich
hoffe dass die zwei neuen team kommen
summa summarum liegt aber im endeffekt
niemand
die dame in rot ist übrigens keine neue
versuchung für die singles sondern
expertin für ski bar eine räte
japanische technik um intimität und
vertrauen in beziehungen zu fördern
ich hab jetzt schon wieder
komischen technik vergessen sushi was
auf ein brett hier vielleicht etwas
gewandelt
nichts lenkt ein besser von sap super
idee was ist punch habe bin ich so
singen dass ich nicht weiß was das ist
ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zwischen weisheit und dem streben und
meint dass harry und von sestak auf der
gleich
ja mein wunsch geht in erfüllung
[Musik]
die haben schon richtig bock wieder
aufeinander bisschen wanted stellt ihr
helfen die ganze sache anders zu sehen
ich will rugby schreien kurz
zwischendurch so schrieb ich hasse so
schmeckt die süße stimme ab wird mich
überhaupt nicht interessieren habt ihr
erfahrungen mit bundes- oder fesseln
warum wehren sie sonst ihr alle von dem
effekt der auch vom abi gefragten das
war doch meine antwort also derjenige
der sich wirklich seinen partner hingibt
top gehälter über drei distanzen
wir bringen ihnen bei dieses prinzip
auch alle facetten ihrer beziehung
anzuwenden
gardel nicht raus
ich schätze es überhaupt nicht das sind
so diese typischen leute die dann so
auch in so einem bild in kunst mal
unternehmen da fabriziert sagen guck mal
das blau steht für die hoffnung und des
grünen steht für das feuer menschen
genauso sorgt bei diesem sushi workshop
da irgendwie ja wenn ihr euch fesselt
dann kann man das vollauf projekts
jedoch eine beziehung und ob alle
anderen situationen ein mann fesselt
sich einfach keine lust ihr gehören wie
erwachsene drüber reden wenn du wirst
das hat nichts mit erwachsenen seien zu
tun
ich stehe für mich ein es hat schon was
mit erwachsenen zu tun für ein scheiß
könne
du hast halt auf der anderen seite mit
einem anderen medien rumgeknutscht weil
du das nicht klären nur aber hass hat
nichts mit erwachsenen sondern zu tun
gab da eine unschöne situation vor ein
paar tagen
es tut mir leid aber ich finde wir
sollten nach vorn sehen
ich würde dich nicht verletzen
das ist eine chance für euch etwas neues
auszuprobieren nutzt eure gefühle dafür
bis zum schluss nicht unterdrücken
er findet sie gut was ist sicher hätte
er könnte sterben an diesem verdammten
sei ihm zu füssen button
ich habe ihm ein bisschen wehgetan und
aggressionen ja komplett aus der
workshop hat wunder gewirkt ok am ein
paar dinge gelernt die mir später
anwenden können das hättest du wohl gern
das schlitzohr cool
dann hatten wir heute den ersten
workshop in unserer reaktion wenn euch
das ganze gefallen hat dann das kann
einen daumen hoch unter dem video hier
da meine lieben freunde schreibt wir da
unten die kommentare was ihr denkt wie
es weitergehen wird wenn jana jetzt bald
sagt hubmann zwei leute rumgeknutscht
denkt ihr das wird auf liegen wer das
war denkt ihr das geht so und so seinen
webinaren bekommen
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt hier
auch im auto meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr noch kein teil der luke schulseite
um einen kanal noch nicht abonniert hat
dann klickt gern hier oben auf den
smiley denn dann werdet ihr teil der lu
crew und wenn ihr bock hab noch nie
wieder zuschauen und klick dass er
anders ist auch meine zweite kanal
online gegangen da reagiere ich auf
ich weiß nicht so einfach an ja da
nichts zu tun ich den ganzen tag